oh please take your seats greetings
folks how's it going excited to be here
today we're gonna be talking about
building nodejs applications on Google
cloud platform we're gonna be building
some apps deploying them to App Engine
talking about taking those same
applications running them on kubernetes
and container engine we're gonna use the
G cloud NPM module to connect our app
with some of the cool services we heard
about this week things like the Google
cloud vision API Google Cloud Storage
and then finally if we have some time at
the end we're gonna dig into the way
that Java Script is helping change the
face of the Internet of Things we got a
lot to do today so before we dig in a
little bit about myself my name is
Justin Beckwith I'm a product manager
here at Google and before that I was a
web developer at a bunch of places if
you want to take a look at any of the
code we're gonna do today all of it's
available on github feel free to go
check it out clone it if you want to ask
any questions reach out to me on Twitter
at Justin Beckwith and you know for me
this is really exciting because know
jess has been a big part of my
development experience for the last five
or six years I was originally on an
engineering team back in 2010 and when
we just we kind of stumbled upon nodejs
because we were primarily a front-end
focused development team and what was
really attractive to us is that finally
we were able to take all these years of
experience we had voting front-end
JavaScript web applications and apply
that same knowledge all that expertise
we'd built on the server side as well we
didn't have to split between front-end
and back-end we had one team that
homogeneously could learn one language
and then use all of that collective
knowledge and one of the things we're
really surprised by when we started
experimenting with it was that without
doing very much work at all we were able
to get great performance out of our
application and you'll see that today
just kind of the way that no js' is
built makes it really easy to build
perform at web apps when we started
digging in we started we started using
Express as our web application server
and we were a little bit surprised by
this because most of other frameworks
would use before we're part of the core
of whatever language we were using but
most of the most of the third-party pack
most of the packages out there for
nodejs
they're really not in the core they're
provided by this third-party module
system called end
and it's wildly popular and there's just
about anything you could ever one out
there with it just last month there were
nearly 4 billion downloads of NPM
packages for authors of nodejs apps that
were building and using these
dependencies and then over the last six
years you know a lot of things have
changed this started up as a technology
where maybe if you're building a new app
and you wanted to experiment or you were
a startup you might decide to use it but
no js' its ready for the enterprise now
there are real companies taking a big
bet and with things like the node
foundation and an 18-month support cycle
it's finally ready to use for enterprise
web applications so in that same time a
lot of things have changed on Google
cloud as well and it's now also a great
place to run web apps as it would turn
out no js' is built on top of v8 the
JavaScript execution engine that's used
by Google Chrome so we have years and
years of experience fine-tuning
JavaScript to run great on the client
and we're bringing that same expertise
to helping build performant applications
on the server and when you are ready to
bring them to us you can take advantage
of Google's infrastructure so you're not
worried about uptime you're not worried
about scaling we're just gonna manage
all that for you and then lastly when
you want to extend your application to
use things like cloud ml vision API
bigquery some of the cool stuff we've
talked about all week you can take
advantage of our api's and services so
we're getting started when you want to
deploy your application to Google cloud
really three places that you're gonna
look at the first is App Engine App
Engine has been around for a while it's
the the most storied part of Google
cloud and the idea is like I mentioned
you just bring your code deployed to us
will scale it we'll manage it for you
if you're an organization that's already
using docker container engine is a great
option as well it's essentially the
Google cloud hosted version of
kubernetes and it's a great option for
those of you who are already into the
container revolution and then finally if
you want to have complete control you
want to run a Windows VM you want to run
a Linux VM and you want to kind of own
that end-to-end you can always create a
virtual machine on compute engine so
first thing I want to do before we dig
into the first demo is we had an
announcement on Monday and nodejs on App
Engine just entered beta so everything
that we're gonna do today you're gonna
be able to go home and do as well
thank you so for the first demo we're
gonna build a simple web application
with Express J s most popular web
framework for node and take a look at
what deploying that to App Engine looks
like so I'm just gonna use the Express
tool noting App Engine specific here I'm
gonna say Express nodejs next and this
is just creating an application on my
local machine so I'm gonna do what the
instructions tell me to do here see the
into the directory and run npm install
now i'm installing these dependencies
locally but when you're deployed into
google cloud into App Engine we're also
gonna run the npm install for you so if
you have any native dependencies they're
gonna get built on the right
architecture so just to show standardout
running locally do npm start our app is
up and running and let's take a look at
this locally so here
nothing fancy we've all probably done
this you know a hundred times getting
started with our projects so let's make
a simple change to it and then deploy it
to App Engine so I'm gonna cancel this
out open up the project in my editor of
choice and all we're gonna do here is
instead of it saying Express we're gonna
say Express now on Google App Engine hey
all right so when you're ready to deploy
your application you're gonna want to go
download the Google Cloud SDK and that's
at cloud.google.com slash sdk and this
provides the g-cloud command line tools
that you can use to orchestrate your
deployments long as a lot of the along
with a lot of the other things we're
gonna see in the UI and a little bit
here so the deploy I'm just gonna do G
cloud preview app deploy first thing
it's gonna do is take a look at our
application figure out okay this is no
js' let's generate an app tamil a small
configuration file that lets us know
what type of application you're running
and so I'm okay with generating that and
finally it's gonna tell us we're about
to deploy our version and we're off and
you can see here we've got no js' next
appspot.com
this is a project that i had set up
earlier i'm deploying to a specific
version because i don't want it
I don't want this to replace the version
I have deployed out there right now and
behind the scenes we're gonna be going
off and creating our app in the App
Engine flexible environment so this is
gonna take a little bit to deploy while
that's happening let's take a look at a
version of this that I have already
deployed out to App Engine so this is
the Google Cloud Developer console and
this is the nodejs project that we had
just created and deployed into
dashboards gonna give us a good
oversight over the performance of our
application let us take a look at
requests we can also dig in if we can
also dig into things like latency
traffic utilization lots of interesting
statistics available from the dashboard
what we're going to take a look at are
the versions of our applications that
are actually available so we just kicked
off a new deployment every deployment
into App Engine is going to create what
we call a new version now you'll notice
that when we when we clicked on that
link it didn't when or when we started
our deployment it didn't say that was
just going to no js' - next appspot.com
it had this version number in front of
it and the reason for that is is that
every deployment that you do in App
Engine creates a new version and we want
to give you the opportunity to go check
it out make sure it works validate
everything with your application your
deployment is working exactly like you
expect it and then only when you're
ready reroute all of your traffic over
to this new version now of course during
the development time you can set it up
so that it does this automatically but
it's a really great feature if you're
building an application that has to have
five nines of reliability and you want
to be extra extra sure that you're not
going to deploy a bad build but first
let's check out the version of this that
I've already deployed so I'm going to
click here on the version v1 open up in
a new window and we have essentially the
same thing that we just started the
deployment for right now now as well as
this v1 version that's getting a hundred
percent of my traffic we're gonna notice
we have yellow green red blue these are
just four different versions of my app
that I deployed that have a different
background color now the reason I'm
bringing this up is because this
versions feature it's not just useful
for you know validating my bill before I
take a new deployment into production
it's also great if I want to do things
like a be testing what if we wanted to
know if you know which background color
of our application is going to provide
the best experience for our users
be able to measure that and use that to
make decisions about the product that
we're deploying into cloud what I can do
is I can actually split the traffic
across those four versions so let's try
doing that I'm gonna take twenty five
twenty five percent one hundred and
twenty five percent of blue 25 percent
of green and so on until we get up to a
hundred percent
finally 25 percent of yellow risk went
on cookie because otherwise this would
be a difficult difficult demo that
happens sometimes we'll just give it a
quick reload but lots of new things
getting deployed this week some of this
stuff you're seeing for the first time
so we're working out a few of the a few
a few of the kinks as we go
great so up and look at that our new
version is actually available so this is
the version we just deployed but let's
do our traffic split one more time I'm
feeling good about it this time
so we have red 25% to blue 25% to green
and 25% to yellow save and well we'll
skip past that at this stage that's okay
these things happen
new code we just had to change out to
the flexible environment but the idea is
that as I come back to this what I'm
gonna see now is that every time traffic
comes in one out of four users will get
red one out of four will get yellow
green and so on so one of the things you
might notice up here is that each of
these versions that's running is behind
mentions that we have two instances now
with the App Engine flexible environment
you can define how many virtual machines
your application is going to run on and
you can limit that to one two you can
tell us to auto scale it which it does
by default to go up to 20 instances by
default but one things that's
interesting is that unlike a lot of
platform-as-a-service systems you might
have used we actually we actually expose
the underlying infrastructure that your
applications running on so if we're
going to get an idea of what's happening
with v1 that's deployed over here we can
click in and we can actually get the
list of the virtual machines
available so now let's say that I want
to actually connect to this and SSH
you could SSH directly into that VM so
another useful thing that you can do
from here is let's say that we wanted to
go and wanted to change we want to I'm
gonna try to do the set traffic command
only this time I'm not gonna use the UI
I'm gonna try to use the command line
you can also use this tool we have
called the cloud shell cloud shell is an
integrated development environment that
includes the Google Cloud SDK all the
commands that I was running locally on
my terminal you can run from here as
well so I'm gonna do G cloud preview app
services Earth let's do versions list
this is going to tell us all the
versions of our applications that are
deployed and what I want to do is I want
to set traffic so that we're gonna route
to the new version that we just went and
created and you can see it has a time
stamp on it so to do that let's say G
cloud preview app services and we're
gonna say set traffic and when we do
that we could of course do a split here
but instead what I'm gonna do is just
send all of my traffic to that version
and we'll say yes
and in just a moment good it looks like
this one actually said so now if I come
back over here and go to no js' next
appspot.com we're gonna see Express now
a Google App Engine the version that we
just deployed up and running and we were
able to do that safely in a way that let
us try it before we actually sent
traffic sent traffic to it so this was a
pretty simple application that we just
made right but let's say that we decided
we don't want to run this on App Engine
anymore or we want to run it in multiple
places what if you wanted to take that
same application you just built and you
want to go run it on kubernetes when
you're ready to do that behind the
scenes all we're really doing with the
App Engine flexible environment is
creating a doctorate into image for you
when you do your deployment that is run
on your virtual machines so you can
actually dig in and take control of the
docker container you can customize it
redeploy to App Engine or you can just
take the whole thing and run it on
container engine kubernetes your own
local machine wherever you want to do
that so let's take a look at how this
works right now we create the docker
file automatically for you but if you
want to get a hold of it you can say
g-cloud preview app gen config - -
custom and what we're gonna do is
generate a docker file for you so quick
show of hands how many people here have
used docker before alright so a fair
number that's actually fantastic I was a
little bit worried I was gonna start
talking about docker and everyone's
gonna get bored and getting that you
know post-lunch phase everyone taking a
nap I don't want any of that so this is
the docker file that we're using behind
the scenes when we're actually building
your image and deploying your
application but let's say we wanted to
do something special we want to do
something different I want to use image
magic I don't know if anyone else is
trying to use image magic on other
passes but it's kind of hard or I want
to do something like use ffmpeg to do
video encoding all you have to do is
come in and just like you would normally
do with a docker container do your
apt-get well first we'll do all right
our update and then your apt-get app get
install image magic
and then we do this a standard docker
build is gonna work just fine docker run
it's gonna work
deploy to kubernetes it's all gonna work
it's the same application that we're
deploying to App Engine
there's no lock-in we're not worried
about it being vendor specific it's just
gonna be portable across any of the this
code will work in any of the engines
that we have and on your machine and
externally as well so a few of the
things that we just covered you know the
big thing I want to drive home with this
is you can run your node J at nodejs
application as it is today
there's no lock-in you can take the code
with you run it wherever you want as far
as NPM modules are concerned use any NPM
module you want you know within within
reason I happen to use Express for this
application
happy J s we're gonna see an example of
that later and work fine Jade you know
any of the modules that you're using
today are gonna work just fine we can
automatically scale this to millions of
requests for you out of the box we're
gonna scale up to 20 instances and you
can bump that up as you need to
the version upgrades and traffic
splitting features are really great
especially once we figure out why that
wasn't working and lastly and most
importantly you can bring your own
runtime with the docker support and it's
not just not just for nodejs this comes
with all the App Engine flexible
runtimes youve complete control over
that environment and it's transparent
you can look in and see what's happening
on the VM so that was a really simple
application I mean that was the classic
kind of hello world deployment but it's
pretty rare that our apps in production
are actually gonna look like that their
difficulty not just App Engine and one
client hitting it usually they look like
something like this right like things
things start to get complex we have you
know multiple modules there were
multiple micro services that we're
managing we're using things like
scalable pub/sub and message queues to
get messages between them we're using a
scalable file system in the cloud to
store all of our files maybe serve them
over a CDN we might need databases we
need things like BigTable datastore or
MongoDB or CouchDB or rethink DB you
know whichever database you're using
today we need to be able to run these
and usually our architectures end up
looking something you know a little bit
more like this by the time
we're done when you're ready to take
advantage of all these services that we
provide things like cloud storage cloud
datastore bigquery that's when you use
the G cloud NPM module so you just I
should say NPM install - - save G cloud
and your project it opens up access to
all the api's and services that we have
on Google cloud so you can expand and
take advantage of the other services
beyond just App Engine or container
engine that we make and make available
and really use come in these big three
buckets right there's storage for things
like using your databases you can use
the databases we provide theories my
sequel with cloud sequel or GCS or
datastore you can do that or you can
bring your own with with things like
MongoDB on compute engine or on
kubernetes oh we have all these cool
things with Big Data I've got bigquery
for accessing you know millions billions
of records in near-real-time
we had some announcements from data lab
pub/sub for Message Queuing and then you
get into the api's which in my opinion
there's api's these are the real magic
of google cloud right these are these
are you know bits of technology that
we've been incubating here internally at
Google for years and years and years and
finally we're able to take some of these
wrap a simple API around them and then
make them available to you to use stuff
like cloud ml speech recognition I know
it's something I've struggled with the
vision API detecting you know we're
looking at a chair or an airplane and
automatically for you these are the
these are the real magic of Google and
they're all exposed I mean think about
the types of apps you could build with
this you could reach billions of people
you could change the world with the
types of applications you could build
with these services I use these services
to build an app about cats that is
actually my cat so I'm sure like many of
you I frequent read it one of the
reddit's that I enjoy is our /aw and one
of the things I noticed while I was on
reddit was that reddit likes to talk a
lot about how they like cats and this
comes up in the internet as well as
developers were all cat friendly yet
every time I went to our /aw I observed
that I felt like I saw more dogs I have
a dog and a cat and you know being being
a
kind of I needed answers to this rightly
I didn't want to just leave it to
perception I needed to do this analysis
and I wanted to know do read it does
read it like dogs or cats more so a
casual observation was not going to
stand here so what I did is I built an
application and what this does is it
goes it loads the first three pages of
our /on you can actually go look at this
right now if you want to you're about to
see the same pictures it loads them up
sends them into Google Cloud storage
runs the cloud vision API against it to
determine if it's a dog a cat or both or
maybe it's a turtle
I don't know figures out what it is
publishes those results back through
cloud pub/sub and then finally through
out the front end module now you notice
here I separated we haven't talked about
modules yet I have an app engine
front-end and an app engine back-end so
I've separated the concerns you can do
that inside of one application and that
way they can scale independently I'm
gonna have a lot more load on the
back-end process than on the front-end
process and it's important when you're
answering questions like this that you
know you can scale cuz I don't want to
wait right I got to know all right so
let's try it out before I keep talking
about it so this is cloud cats and this
is gonna go do this analysis for us in
real time so right now we're going to
read it I hope it's up and there we go
we're start to get the first images in
and of course the first ones that a bear
is that actually a dog
either way it's calming as a dog that's
all that matters
all right the cats are getting back in
it we've got some cute kittens hind
behind there that one looks like a tiger
okay it's fine oh we have cuddling dogs
funny ear dog but you can see dogs on
the right cats on the left and we're
counting them all the way and this
analysis is happening in real-time with
with the Google cloud vision API and
pub/sub so all right I feel like I've
been seeing more dogs and cats we've got
about 75 images the process we've got it
that should count as like four dogs look
at that there are four dogs in that
picture and look at that my casual
observation confirmed with data
organizing the world's information
people this is what we do here at Google
all right so let's take a look at the
code or maybe not and we'll get there
all right into cloud cats so first thing
you'll notice here is we've got the web
module and the worker module separate
out as two independent nodejs
applications I'm gonna dig into the
worker first thing I want to call out as
I mentioned earlier this is using
--happy instead of Express so any web
framework you want to use no web
framework I hear that's popular you can
just use whatever you like
we have no restrictions on the npm
modules you can import the real magic
here though is happening inside of
vision j/s this is on github you can go
check this out you can see here the
first thing we do is import the g-cloud
NPM module now this NPM module it has
access to all of our services so I just
happen to be using two in this part of
the code base I'm using the vision API
and the storage API now the real
interesting piece of this code is right
here it's these four lines of code so
lines 22 to 25 and those four lines of
code we're downloading a picture from
reddit we're saving it to Google Cloud
storage this right here is using node.js
it's just using the standard streams API
just like you would with FS to pipe the
image after we download it directly to
Google Cloud storage and then once
that's done we're gonna run it through
image analysis that tells us if it's a
dog a cat or neither or both that's
magic that's four lines of code we just
deployed something into a scalable file
system in the cloud and ran an image
analysis of that I could have never able
to taken at any of us years and years
and years of collective knowledge to go
build and that's really the magic that's
behind this thing so after we've
evaluated all of these images were then
I mentioned publishing it up through
cloud pub/sub and that's what let's our
front end nodes know that the image
analysis on one record is done let's
take a quick peek at that code again
using the g-cloud npm module
and Google cloud pub/sub has this this
concept called a topic think of it kind
of like a channel and the idea is that I
can publish many things into a topic and
then consumers will all create
subscriptions to that topic to read it
out later we'll see this in a minute
so we're gonna get a topic and then
we're gonna publish our events as they
get as they get published from the
backend service so we're gonna say is it
a dog is it a cat is it both it's
important to be fair and then finally
we're gonna take that data and publish
it out to the front end so now let's
take a look at the front end web process
this one also happens to be happy J s
but the real interesting code is in here
inside of cat relay probably the first
and last time we'll ever create a node
module called cat relay and here you're
gonna see st. similar code importing the
module I'm using PubNub to send messages
out to the connected web clients but you
can use firebase for this as well I just
happened to know PubNub grabbed the same
topic grabbed the subscription and then
here's where the real magic is happening
get the topic the subscription finally
once each of these are published we're
gonna send them out through PubNub with
the final message letting us know if
it's a dog or a cat now while I was
building this application one of the
problems I ran into was I kept getting
some data inside of this message object
but I didn't really expect and these
kinds of things can be hard to debug
especially when you're dealing with live
data coming from something like Reddit
or the shape of the Jason kind of moves
around a little bit and debugging this
traditionally doubling this locally is
something that I could do but debugging
it once you're in cloud it's kind of
hard right like you have to go sifting
through all the logs so one of the tools
I had in my disposal that I want to show
you guys next is called Google Cloud
debugger so check this out I'm gonna
come back over to the developer console
we don't need this right now and I'm
gonna switch my projects over to the
cloud cats project and then I'm gonna go
into the Google cloud debugger now I
happen to have published all of my code
into Google Cloud source repositories so
that I have access to it for debugging
and you can see over here the same code
that we were looking at on my
machine is available here inside of the
developer console this is where it gets
really cool I can come into cat relay
find that one line of code where I
wanted to know exactly what was inside
of that message object that I was
passing through to PubNub and we can set
a breakpoint now this breakpoint it's
not a traditional debugger break point
of view so you used eclipse or Visual
Studio it's a passive debugger what this
means is that people can be running
against our application in production
and we're able to capture call stack and
and variable information without
affecting performance without stopping
execution so we can actually come back
over here I can start to run the
simulation again get a few more pages of
data and as soon as it hits this look at
that it just hit it that code got hit in
real time inside of App Engine I'm able
to go in take a look at the call stack
and most importantly I can come and
debug the variables that are in the
local scope so I can see okay this
message I want to know what data is in
there here's the ID here's the data
object here's the URL that is going out
to Reddit and the type wasn't dog or cat
it was other so this is a pretty
incredible experience if you've ever had
a problem in production that you needed
a bug another useful thing we have out
there for debugging production issues
let's say you're noticing a decrease in
performance we can also go use Google
Cloud trace now a trace does is it
measures the amount of time like during
light during minor HTTP requests and
breaks it down into each other network
requests that I'm making during the
initial one so for something like cloud
cats we were talking to reddit we were
downloading images we were uploading
them to Google Cloud storage we were
calling api's we're using pub/sub we had
Network requests all over the place I
want to measure I want to know which
ones what's the long poem intent what's
making it slow how do i do bug that and
using cloud trace I can do that and here
you can see there's our sample we ran
one minute ago the go endpoint is the
one that I was using to measure all of
the to measure all this stuff and here
we have it so the request was 10 seconds
long
it was doing a lot of stuff so I don't
feel bad about that we made the first
request to Reddit second request I asked
for three pages of data they have to be
serial because of the way they
the next token on it and then in
parallel we go download all the images
off reddit media we upload them all the
Google cloud storage you can see this
going into the bucket and then you can
see and then you can see us starting to
analyze them with the vision API so it
turns out in this case thing was taking
a long times actually calling the API
but if let's say that we found something
where we needed to paralyze something of
a serial this is a great tool to tell us
what's taking time during our requests
for our applications with barely a
performance head in production so when
we're building our applications for the
cloud and we're cutting we're kind of
converting from something that is that
is we have full control over and we need
we need to really understand how it's
performing we need these types of tools
we need cloud to bugger we need trace
tools we need better logging and when it
comes to building nodejs applications in
the enterprise there's no one better to
talk to than Joe McCann CEO and
co-founder of node source thanks Justin
there's nothing like talking about
enterprise application development right
after a cat demo so thanks for that
so I'm Joe McCann and I work at node
source who is node source we are the
enterprise nodejs company currently only
offering the the only commercial version
of nodejs explicitly targeted at the
enterprise use cases of node so a rough
analogy is kind of think of us as what
Red Hat does for Linux we kind of do
that for nodejs but how did we even earn
sort of the right to have a commercial
version of nodejs well at node source we
love node in fact we have the most core
committers contributors to the open
source project itself including the
node.js lead rod [ __ ] who also represents
the technical steering committee on the
node.js Foundation board of directors so
at node source we we know note we love
it we love the open source project but
we also really know node in the
enterprise right here's a handful of our
customers that we've worked with in the
past where we've seen node at scale over
the past few years and a lot of folks
someone that on this slide for example
have had challenges that they needed met
but even with these folks on this slide
I still get this question a lot is node
really ready for the enterprise now I
might be a little bit biased because I
have an enterprise node.js company that
I work at but I think the answer really
is in fact yes we are ready
there are hundreds if not thousands of
enterprises out there actually using
node from from folks like you know into
its Netflix to Apple BMW Capital One
NASA etc this is a it's actually more
difficult to find a company in the
global 2000 that's not using node in
some capacity so we we believe and we've
seen it empirically that node is
actually really ready for the enterprise
the thing though about an open source
project or even node specifically is
when you get it into the enterprise
there are some challenges that that face
its adoption and integration and the
obvious ones are things around security
is know to secure of course it is but
there are some additional sort of
demands brought by certain industries
around how to harden that runtime or who
do we call and something's broken who's
who's the the entity backing this open
source project and then more
specifically with node how do we get
better control over the runtime and
better insight into things like finding
bhatta little performance bottlenecks
and debugging the applet the application
well this is precisely why we built our
product and solid and solid is in fact
the enterprise grade node.js platform
and to be clear it's not a fork of node
it actually is no js' with an additional
set of capabilities wrapped around it so
it doesn't break interoperability in
fact you don't even have to touch your
application code whatsoever and the
capabilities that install it actually
provides well there are the things that
the enterprise's have told us they
really need things like enhanced
security guard rails
production monitoring of these processes
turn-key performance analysis so you
know we don't want to have to use a
bunch of system tools just to profile
this how do we get real-time performance
analysis of course I mentioned things
like support that stability from a
commercial vendor and I think one of the
best parts as a developer and and how we
architected this early on is there's no
code modification required so the
application that you've currently
written in nodejs
will work with n solid by default and
I'm really pleased earlier this week we
actually announced our partnership with
Google cloud so n solid is in fact
available on Google cloud so let me show
you a couple of demos so let's change
our project to node source first and we
are actually running on compute engine
and so if you look here what you'll see
is a handful of VMs with some various
nodejs applications now in production
you wouldn't do this you would actually
run an auto scaling managed instance
group as opposed to just a handful of
VMs but it's a demo so we can we can
deal with this now what you see here is
a handful of apps and this one in
particular this is Dillinger this is
actually it's a real application it's an
online mark down editor and we see here
there's some interesting CP utilization
it's kind of hovering a bit high there
which is odd for a node.js application
node.js has a low memory footprint and
that typically has a low CPU utilization
so something's interesting is going on
and in the in the Google cloud Developer
console we can see it from a high level
but what n solid does is it provides us
deeper insight from a bottoms-up
approach so just so that you believe me
let me show you that Dillinger is in
fact a real app so we click on the URL
there it is running yes it is in fact a
real markdown editor and then if we want
to go see dive in deeper into Dillinger
as it's just kind of triage what the
issue is why is that CPU running so high
we're actually going to launch into the
end solid console so all of those
applications that showed previously on
the developer console for Google cloud
are all right here in the end solid
console as well and lo and behold we're
gonna dive
deeper into Dillinger and we can see
very quickly that there are a couple of
processes that are kind of scattered out
there towards the right now it might be
a little difficult to see from here but
the x-axis is measuring CPU utilization
and the y-axis is memory and what we've
noticed from the folks that we've worked
at with in the past and those sources
it's some of the two major you know key
issues that people have with nodejs
development is memory leaks and
determining where our bottlenecks are in
our code so we already can see quickly
there is something kind of going wrong
or interesting something worth
inspecting is you should say with this
particular process
so if we look we get a little bit more
detailed view here but it's not really
telling us much because there's not any
load actually hitting it so why don't we
go ahead and we'll go ahead and trigger
some load with Apache bench this is an
open source load testing tool actually
Google has a really awesome distributed
load testing tool but just for ease of
use we'll just go with Apache bench for
now so given the latency of the Wi-Fi
and anything else what we should see in
near-real-time is these these processes
actually reacting to the traffic and
what we want to do with a few clicks of
the button is actually profile this
application and generate what's called a
flame graph and if you've never
generated a flame graph it's okay
basically what you're looking for in a
flame graph is the width of these
function calls and how long they're
sitting on in CPU and what we can see
very quickly here is this average time
function it's taking up 77% of the call
the CPU utilization for this particular
process now what we're doing here is is
somewhat magical but it's meant to
actually help drive towards issue
resolution faster we can see from this
line here this is actually where that
function is defined and we can
immediately go and figure out what went
wrong with the writing of that function
to make it so slow this is only a
snapshot of the capabilities that
installer provides we do have a booth
out front I recommend people coming by
to see some of the enhanced security
guard rails that we have show you some
of the heat snapshot capabilities
but in the meantime I will say I'm
really excited to be working with Justin
the team because the the scale of Google
cloud and and the history that they have
behind compute in Texas intensive tasks
coupled with something like n solid
really can help drive home no js' apps
in the enterprise Thank You great job
Thank You Jo so we've done a lot today
we've run JavaScript on the client we
obviously had a few demos there we ran
it on the server let's cut one of my
favorite things about nodejs and about
javascript specifically is that it runs
everywhere we're gonna get on our phones
on our desktops on servers and now we're
even seeing it start to run on other
alternative devices one of my favorite
quotes out there comes from Jeff Atwood
have stackoverflow frame which is
anything that can be written in
JavaScript will eventually be written in
JavaScript and I think where we're
really starting to see that claim come
to life is with the Internet of Things
so IOT is exploding right now and one of
the top languages that people are
picking to choose is JavaScript and a
big reason for that is that it's
ubiquitous it's everywhere people
already know it all those skills that
we've learned throughout the last 10 15
years building front-end JavaScript apps
and now the last six seven years
building backend apps we can apply to
devices in the cloud as well there are a
lot of great options out there if you
have something like an Arduino or if you
have something like a Raspberry Pi there
are some NPM modules johnny-five Cylon
j/s that make using these devices really
really simple and Google's getting
involved here too we have things like
brillo and weave some new protocols and
tools that are out there to help and
even help connect them with Android now
when you do build something that's IOT
based let's say that we go out and we
have a car or a washing machine that's
internet connected you're gonna generate
a lot of data bigquery is a great tool
that we can use when it's time to
actually tame that data and try to
gather some insights out of it but all
that sounds you know though it sounds
great and exciting what I wanted to do
today is we have a little bit of time
left we have six minutes left I'm gonna
have some fun and what I wanna do is I'm
gonna show a toy
now these toys right here and they may
be kind of hard
these are called little bits and little
bits are these tiny little electronic
building block components they're great
for the young or the young at heart and
they really they're about teaching
children electronics and about getting
getting excited about making things
that's I know that's something that I
wanted to share and so the next part
we're gonna dig into is how we can use
little bits connect them to the Internet
and then actually control them with
nodejs
on google cloud so before we dig into
before we dig into the actual demo I
want to take a look at a little bit of
code there we go so this is the Hat spin
project and I'm going to open up server
j/s and you think I'm back to using
Express again I just want to walk
through a few the NPM modules I'm using
and talk about how they're gonna
communicate with these devices so here
we have the little bits API and that's
that's using little bits cloud HTTP and
they have an NPM module you can install
that will actually communicate with this
thing over cloud pretty simple to use
again I'm using PubNub to connect to an
internet-connected client so we're gonna
see a web page here in a little bit
in this case I happen to be using Redis
to store a few results so you could use
Google cloud you could use memcache but
if you want to come to use Redis that's
perfectly fine I'm using Redis labs as
an example right here just just because
it was easy to set up and then let's get
down to the part that's actually doing
something interesting when you guys
click on a button and a link that I'm
gonna send you out in a little bit I'm
having a little bit of problem with my
device I have to reset it over here give
me one second make sure that my phone is
serving everything the way it's supposed
to all right sorry for the interruption
and so with a little bit of luck
assuming the technology doesn't fail us
today this is all very new every time we
come in here and click we're gonna count
we're gonna try to get up to 100 clicks
and once we get to 100 we're gonna send
a 20-second high edge signal to a device
so now let's take a look at what type of
device we're going to use so some of you
may have seen this movie where there's a
bunch of guys that try to get a job at
Google
and in the end they do get a job and
when they're finished with that they get
one of these fancy hats right now I was
very excited when I got my noogler hat
and the first the very first thing I
thought to myself when I got it was you
know what I better connect this thing to
the Internet cuz I'm at Google now and
that's what we do right and so oh my
gosh it's not starting up and so I went
and we we built this and what I want
everyone to do is I want you to go out
to hat spin dotnet and see if we can
coax my hat to wake up and activate
unfortunately right now it's it's giving
me a little bit of trouble but I'm gonna
hope for the best and worst case I look
like a fool in front of a roomful of
people
whatever wouldn't be the first time all
right so I'm running hat spin over here
and what I can do is I can actually
watch oh and let's hear I'm gonna reset
it all right if you voted voting so fast
all right unfortunately unfortunately
it's having a little bit of trouble with
the Wi-Fi even though it was working
earlier
I apologize folks I'm gonna get this
working after the event if you want to
come up and see it and we'll give it a
try again in a little bit all right so
we covered a lot of stuff today we had
some ups we had some downs we had some
hats App Engine is making it easy to
operate Google at Google scale so the
applications that you're writing today
we want to make it as simple as possible
for you to focus on building the app and
not having to worry about the
infrastructure you can use the tools and
libraries you're already using use the
things that you know the things that you
love when you are ready if you want to
take advantage of our amazing api's and
services that's available to you and
that's really the magic that's behind
Google cloud and finally the big thing
is that no js' and Google cloud together
we're all ready for the enterprise we're
ready for serious applications not just
hats and cats but we're ready for the
real applications that are needed out
there today to change the world
everything we looked at today and to end
is
source the doctor images were using the
g-cloud NPM library trace and debugger
tools the API client all the samples
everything we're doing is in the open
and the clear and we want your feedback
on this get involved open issues tell us
if something doesn't work tell us if it
does work and you like it we want to
make sure that you get involved and
lastly thank you